25 years ago
an epic motion picture was unleashed on
America considered one of the most
important films in history we are now
proud to release this masterpiece on DVD
for the very first time this
one-of-a-kind 25th anniversary
commemorative edition Beaches extras
including cast interviews director
commentary and never-before-seen
outtakes catch all the gals spills and
hilarious practical jokes your name is
Toby hooter Kinte I said your name is
Toby Kunta Kinte damn State when I say
by him so hardly alright sorry I'm so
sorry
[Applause]
[Music]
25th anniversary commemorative edition
on DVD including our raw bomb
[Applause]